ليست مجرده ثلاث نقاط تاريخيه على احد
اقوى منتخبات العالم لكنه فوز يكتب ويسجل
العديد من الارقام لصالح المنتخب السعودي
وكاس العالم بشكل عام لاول مره في تاريخ
مشاركته الست بكاس العالم ليفتتح المنتخب
السعودي منافسته الموندياليه بالفوز وتلك
المره على راقصه تانجو في نفس الوقت تفتح
الارجنتين مشوارها في كاس العالم بالخساره
لاول مره منذ سقوطها في مباراه الكاميرون
بمونديال 1990 فوز السعوديه على الارجنتين
يكتب رابع انتصار للصقور الخضر في
منافساته بكاس العالم وهو رقم عربي وقيسي
متفوقا على الجزائر الذي يملك ثلاث
انتصارات هو اول فوز عربي على منتخب من
امريكا الجنوبيه في كاس العالم منذ 40
عاما حين فازت الجزائر على تشيلي في
مونديال عام 1982
لاول مره منذ عام 1930 تخسر الارجنتين
مباراه في كاس العالم بعد تقدمها خلال
الشوط الاول
اخيرا فوز الصقور يعني انهاء سلسله الله
هزيمه لمنتخب الارجنتين والتي استمرت لست
وثلاثين مباراه متتاليه